foreign
[Music]
exit the core hands exit the core
exit the car I
added the car put it in car
yeah
right here hands on the hood
hands on the hood you have a gun
stop arguing hands on the horse my hand
is on the hood
be entertained wow
see what they doing to me back in front
of Zoe's Kitchen hurry up you see what
they're doing
hey
[Music]
going there
why y'all doing all this why it costs
for all these thoughts because they said
you shot a gun over there huh
I got me I got one female security
as I go to the
um
thank you
just put her in the car in there
McDonald's okay yeah we got this
there we go
you just came here hello
[Music]
this is
awesome
you're pulling away from him away from
him
just keep her in the car
um
well I follow